kyle is in grand rapids michigan hey
kyle how are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
appreciate everything you guys do
and the opportunity to discuss my
situation
sure what's up so yeah let's get into it
i'm married with three young children
i'm in debt i hate my job i'm having a
problem with drinking and i'm just
feeling uninspired broken and exhausted
i've been working the debt but i have a
ways to go
and i can't seem to get out of my own
way when it comes to figuring out my
career
and getting my health together if you
guys need a little bit more backstory i
can give it to you but basically i would
just like some advice on
how to proceed because i've been
struggling emotionally since before my
kids were born and i'm
still not happy with where i am which i
feel bad saying but but that's where i'm
at
sure i want you to be as just brief but
very descriptive
on you keep getting in your own way as
it relates to figuring out what you want
to do with your career what does that
mean
so i feel like i just keep coming in
hitting these mental road blocks so i'll
i'll sober up and stay focused for a
week two weeks at a time
and then something will happen will
trigger me emotionally to want to drink
or to do something that's not related to
the career i want to have and a lot of
times i don't know if it's
circumstantial or if i'm getting in my
own way
in my heart of hearts i feel like i can
fix it and that i'm just kidding
in my own way but at the same time i'm
in the grind of
i'm in the grind of early parenthood and
i'm dealing with a lot of pressure from
the career i currently have and i'm the
breadwinner
i get you our most of our annual income
comes from my job so i feel like most of
my focus has to go there
sure all right family and it's getting
in the way of who i am
sure so kyle that so i'm hearing lots of
things so the emotional stuff
you need to get some professional help
on that i'll talk about that in just a
moment but
you've had some ideas based on what i'm
hearing you have some ideas you may have
one clear idea that if i could snap my
fingers and put you in it
on monday morning knowing you couldn't
fail i gotta sense that you have an idea
or two
am i right or am i wrong on what you
would do yeah you're right what is it
no more and listen here's what i want to
do for the next just for the next couple
seconds
i don't want you to think don't think
don't qualify i want you to answer my
questions agreed
agreed here we go what is it tell me
what it is what would you do tomorrow if
you knew you couldn't fail
i'm i'm apprehensive saying it because
it seems true but honestly i'd like to
get into game development
game development now you did what i told
you not to do but that's okay because we
got the answer
you want to be a developer for video
games yes or no
yes okay do you have the baseline
technical talent that if you were
trained pop properly that you know that
you could develop effectively
game technology yes or no
i would need additional training i don't
think so so the answer is yes
you have the core talent if you were
trained and educated
you could do it do you believe that if i
was trained yes
all right so hey you gotta say for one
second kyle i want you to throw off all
the self-doubt that's hanging on you
like a
giant winter coat throw it off
you can't even answer a question about
yourself because of the doubt and i know
there's a lot going on
and i get that but brother i just want
you to get real for a moment no wait a
second do i have the technical talent
now let me ask you this
why i want you to give me a short answer
why would you want to develop
for video games what's the why behind
that
because i like creating experiences
there you go
always had a knack for technical stuff
and always had a knack i always had an
interest in experiences yes
yes okay and you're a gamer that's right
so here's the deal you think because
you're a dad of three small
kids you guys have got some debt and
you're dealing with some emotional stuff
which is driving you to drink
you're thinking i'll never get there is
that about right
yeah i mean but that's not true but
that's not true so let me let me let me
challenge you
all right you need to understand that
there is a path
so you know what you want to do if you
if you could just make it happen you
know what you want to do so you're in
that get clear stage now it's all about
getting qualified
so you have to actually do the homework
and not get
stuck in the bottle and doubt and
insecurity and fear about what it's
going to look like go
what would it take what has to be true
for me to be qualified
to actually apply for jobs like that and
someone hire me is it starting out in
another development role and getting
development experience somewhere else
and then crossing over the video game
industry there's lots of different paths
brother i'm telling you
one thing i want you to do is call
bethel tech betheltech.net they're a
partner of the ken coleman show
and they take adults from zero
technology experience
zero to working in the technology
industry in nine months
less than 15 grand you're not there yet
you got to get your debt paid off
dave ramsey ramsey solutions we could
help you with that but you got to
believe that you can get there
and then i think you got to get healthy
dave i think he's got to get healthy and
he's got to get on the debt elimination
plan
and we put the dream on hold doesn't
mean it's gone
doesn't mean we never get there but
you've got to get out of debt
and you've got to get healthy
emotionally to where you believe
that you do have what it takes and that
you have a unique contribution so that
you're not
leaning towards the bottle
so are you guys involved in are you guys
involved in church at all
no not you're not how old are you
i'm 34. okay
all right when i was a young dad um i
wasn't either and i wandered in the back
door one it changed my whole life
because i got men and women in my life
that would walk beside me
as i changed some of the habits i needed
to change to be successful
and i like that idea and i i have i have
asked
my wife about that because we're
yearning for that sense of community and
i feel like
just that just the overall message and
sense of community whether we're
religious or not would would be helpful
exactly so we almost went to church
for that reason alone that's okay that
doesn't mean that won't make anybody mad
even the people at the church just go
over there and make some friends with
good people
and good people walk beside you and once
they're good enough friends to reach
over and pop you on the back of the head
if you're drinking too much that's a
really good friend
right yeah you need a butt you need some
buddies in your life man you need a band
of brothers
they love you enough to knock a knot on
your noggin
i agree with that and you can pick it up
there and you wouldn't hurt to step into
a 12-step
program wouldn't hurt to sit down with a
a good counselor
and uh because you know what it amounts
to is you're stuck and the way you get
unstuck you get new information and new
inspiration
yes sir and um and and that helps you
then build a vision
for your life that ken was laying out
for you that you can believe in
and when you believe in that vision then
you can run through walls to get there
and you can set down the things that are
causing you to stumble
and um we've all got them man i ain't
different than you me and ken
if you count up the stupid butt stuff
between the two of us that we've done
you couldn't fill out you can fill a
room with it so you but you got to set
down the stuff that's killing you
and pick up the stuff that gives you the
energy and that's goal
setting and inspiration information good
people in your life good community in
your life
so yeah that's my assignment for you
and then walk with uh ken over at
kingcoleman.com and he'll get you the
job